welcome back to me rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of chip and
dale rescue rangers on disney plus
starring andy samberg and john mulaney
in a 2022 reboot directed by akiva
shaffer a modern day who framed roger
rabbit packed with cameos so let's break
down some that you might have missed the
opening disney title card of
cinderella's castle gets zapped in the
way that this movie bastardizes iconic
disney imagery into bootleg forms elsa's
ice castle from frozen and the retro
version of the castle from pixar's
incredibles the sultan's palace from
agrabah from aladdin and i think i'm not
sure though prince eric's castle from
the little mermaid which we gotta talk
about the design of that castle he parks
his ship right in there got a private
staircase down to a beach i want to live
in there then we open in 1982 when dale
mentions 18th century furniture designer
thomas chippendale which according to
the disney story artist tex henson who
drew these characters in the 40s was the
origin of their name now one of the
groundbreaking things about hoofer and
roger rabbit was the way director robert
zemeckis blended animation with live
action props and gags and right away
there's a little stun here as the
teacher pulls live action headphones off
the animated kid then she calls out
betty for not wearing any pants like
donald duck which is so sad some
cartoons have to wear pants others don't
there's no rules hard to be a pubescent
kid going to school in the cafeteria one
of the kids looks like ash ketchum for
pokemon another kid animated in the
style of the simpsons chip is a night
rider lunchbox and as they become
friends they watch a clip of abbott and
costello from the 1954 private eye
routine where they're handcuffed but
costello is swapped out for the
character crispy cow who they later have
a poster for in their place in la we see
how they book a part on full house with
the sisters of the scarlet witch that's
how i will refer to them now and we see
the intro to the animated chippendale
rescue rangers tv series and this movie
actually brings back most of the voice
cast tres mcneil comes back as gadget
and chips chipmunk voice whenever they
go into that gag corey burton comes back
as zipper and dale's chipmunk voice jim
cummings comes back as fat cat in this
movie eric bana voices monty now the
movie who framed roger rabbit opens with
one of the most insane animated live
action transitions ever in cinema from
roger's animated short revealed as a
live action set painted to look like a
tune and we get a knot of that here as
this movie's director a cameo by
director akiva shaffer yells cut on this
short we pull out and reveal it as a
sound stage right behind him is a cameo
by professor norton nymnal then on to
the wrap party where we see a dh paula
abdul dancing with mc skatcat from the
opposite of tracks music video they're
all dancing with the three little pigs
and roger rabbit charles fleischer
actually returning to voice him
all right what a
dale reveals he's booked a role in james
bond parody double o dale airing on har
presumably a comedy network like comedy
central because later on posters and
billboards we see some of these titles
streaming on horror plus under the
present where dale's convention is
filled with cosplayers and cameos
everywhere you look there is a cameo
every everybody's something i like how
there are mice dressed as princess leia
and kylo ren with the lightsabers blues
on stage singing bear necessities looks
like that's trusty from lady and the
[ __ ] on sax i love all the background
movie posters one here shows pirates of
the great lakes dale is not on the main
stage he just has a booth beside lumiere
marvel's tigra we don't see him but the
booth beside them is cronk from
emperor's new groove and of course ugly
sonic the pre-redesigned from the 2019
trailer that freaked everyone out here
voiced by tim robinson in my opinion the
funniest sketch actor watches netflix
series and i love that close-up of his
creepy human teeth a few loose hairs
just sticking out over the lip and poor
tigra has to remind us of her marble
ties because she just has a sad avengers
assemble draped over her desk meanwhile
chip sells insurance to a sheep who has
the same stop-motion design as sean from
the wallace and grommet movies ash
ketchum appears again behind ship in the
office and i like the gag how he works
for coercive insurance chip's neighbor
is mrs house growing up from the 1952
disney short the little house in his
freezer is ice age ice cream frozone
food and looney tunes pasta with fog or
legord on it which is an actual product
from tyson in the 90s chip sees a promo
for the rapping recently rebooted alvin
and the chipmunks their cgi makeover is
the same exact redesign dale gets
another point of contention between
these two monty explains what happened
to poor flounder from the little mermaid
how about this isn't it neat
come on fellas this is a genuine bengal
hopper yeah he uses ariel's word for a
fork in this movie flounder is voiced by
rachel bloom wife of the co-writer dan
gregor rachel bloom actually voices a
number of characters in this movie now
in hoovering drudge rabbit the tunes
feared the dip but in this movie it's
bootlegging wherein poor forgotten
cartoons are disfigured and cast and
knock-off versions of animated films
bootleg flatterings up and little
mermaid parody the small fish lady
arielle is wearing a sports bra instead
of a clam bra and eric has a five
o'clock shadow and you can see at the
top of it it says from the creators of
beauty and the cursed dog man a poster
that also shows up in sweet pete's
office on the walk of fame chip passes
the stars for squidward yogi bear and
samurai jack later chun li and there are
a whole bunch of parody movie posters
fast and furious babies rated r
president dog three then meryl streep is
mr doubtfire same family new imposter
batman vs e.t a gucci ad with dobby from
harry potter chip later watches batman
vs e.t e.t
forgive
bat
fine yeah e.t was voiced by akiva
shaffer batman by lonely island
collaborator jerome tacon now it is not
called out explicitly but dale's play is
actually an erotic dance club
specifically based on that guy's bow tie
chippendales at the crime scene one of
the lapd cars has the design of the
pixar cars universe same as the one that
dale's car bumper almost hits inside we
see the donut cops from wreck-it ralph
and we need cheap putty voiced by jk
simmons an original character but later
described as a low rent gumby his
knockoff nature being a clue to his true
motives as they drive on the sunset
strip we see more great billboards waze
the movie johnny bravo fitness the
butter boys and then nickelodeon's doug
as a law firm funny in pork chop your
injury is not funny dale's plate reads
vip monk vip monk now as they approach
main street some of the graffiti in the
background is miles morales expectation
street art from spider-man into the
spider-verse on to main street that i'm
pretty sure it's just main street usa at
disneyland we see a colonel from 101
dalmatians in the window blowing bubbles
and then linda from phineas and ferb
selling cupcakes we see wart and maps
fat cats henchmen from rescue rangers in
the background that flower girl who's
also voiced by rachel bloom is designed
to at least look like one of the sugar
rush racers in wreck-it ralph and then
shopping for a chipmunk wig is mr
natural a real deep cut a 60's zen
master figure we meet bjornsson the
cheese seller a muppet like the swedish
chef voiced by kiki michael keith inside
there's one rat with a scarf who just
really savors the cheese looking a lot
like remy from ratatouille biryan yells
at an off-screen lester no more free
samples which could be a nod to lester
the lab rat in beekman's world in the
truck chip references jessica rabbit
from who framed roger rabbit and then on
to the uncanny valley which is a pretty
clever reference for la locals because
the valley is what we call the suburban
industrial in dead san fernando valley i
mean no offense man i lived there for
nine years and i love it it's really the
best place to live in l.a fight me on
that i'm gonna have phone with your
coolest police but we don't get like
random brownouts up there meanwhile of
course the uncanny valley is a term that
you've probably heard a lot lately for
animation design and robotics design and
cgi design that tries to simulate human
characteristics too well and it just
comes off as creepy in this we see the
cats from the 2019 live action cats and
npc walking into a hydrant and then seth
rogen shows up playing another example
of the creepy uncanny valley design bob
parody of gimli from lord of the rings
but with lifeless polar express eyes
polar express being a common example of
this effect polar express and who frame
roger rabbit both robert zemeckis
productions the guy is a visual genius
it's just some of his later forays to
push the limits of animation technology
and have been a bit less well received
looking at you welcome morrowind sweet
pete's factory melts down unsold merch
including shrek body wash into
porta-potties willarnette voices the
movie's villain as sweet pete a
middle-aged version of the disney peter
pan he has captain hook's ship in a
bottle and he says bangarang the lost
boys battle cry and hook he later crows
like a rooster saying kookaroo guru his
polar bear thug jimmy is voiced by
dennis haysberg who also voices less
squeaky version of zipper in this movie
he is clearly a coca-cola polar bear
like notice his christmas vest but it
looks like they were not able to get the
rights from coke because later they have
that meta joke of you owe me a non-brand
specific cola here he's reading tunes
magazine on the back is pepe cologne for
pepe le pew pete talks about his own
aging and obsolescence leading him
turning out knock-offs of classics like
flying bedroom boy he won't get old
beauty and a dog man with a freaky mrs
potts and a knockoff cogsworth and then
jasper the dead ghost kid as well as
spaghetti dogs from the creators of
lionwood and nosetoyboy pete's story
actually mirrors the tragic real life
story of bobby driscoll a disney child
actor who provided the voice and the
appearance of 1953's peter pan but once
this poor kid hit puberty he was cruelly
dropped by the studio and as he got
older he got addicted to narcotics and
then died at the age of 31. now most of
the big hollywood studios have horror
stories just like this and this movie's
got some nerve burn working it into
sweet beef's backstory but like the way
who framed roger abbott really exposes
la's history of redlining in the real
estate wars of the 40s this movie
exposes other ways hollywood was built
on broken dreams and while escaping in
the sewer they grab onto the hair of a
doll but it's rapunzel from tangled so
the hair just lets out further and
further until the head just completely
pops off you like how chip flies up
through the pipes buried underground
above him is a skeleton that kind of
looks like the simpsons angel skeleton
from the least of the skeptic episode
and they pop out beside a lego
miserables billboard ellie tells a story
about a bogus raid that she led in the
past to a nick jr studio about how paw
patrol attacked sergeant henderson so he
can't have kids later putty mentions
getting attacked by rugrats and makes
another call out to peppa the pig dale
shows off his garage that's filled with
merch including fireworks from the
disneyland parade this is all actual
chippendale merch including the capcom
nintendo game and they mentioned
episodes of calories not included throw
a mummy off the train and dirty wrong
diapers are all actual episodes of the
rescue rangers series and the lamp on
the desk is if you look at the label a
pixar luxo lamp dale says the monty pog
had a cloud that looked like
oprah and if you're a 90s kid like me
you know that this is a nod to the
claims that disney artists hid some
sexual imagery in the dust of the lion
king and triton's castle in the art of
the little mermaid poster then in the
bath house are more cameos randy march
from south park scrooge mcduck animals
that i assume are the live-action jungle
book animals and then the snake dj herze
voiced by flula borg he plays a remix of
the actual disney afternoon theme music
and pete's locker is a bottle of moana
macadamia nuts onto the san pedro lab
showing drawings of the characters
they've bootlegged including poor jiminy
cricket turned into a snail syndrome
from incredibles given sideshow bob hair
flounder given lips gus guts from
cinderella given a bigger nose felix the
cat made thinner it looks like sneezy
given ears garfield given huge muscles
and then to the left of that we see the
name foghorn and it's something about
two heads now the machine scans chip and
dale into different animation styles
first it looks like mercer mayor's
little critter also some anime style
rick and morty and then classic ubi
works era disney simpson style archie
and jughead a batman and a deadpool ren
and stimpy and it looks like the disney
robin hood you know those low set hips
and that casual sexy lean one of the
lasers turns chips ear into a snoopy ear
then they see a horrifying wall of
harvested bootleg parts including
monty's mustache jiminy cricket's hat
and umbrella pikachu's tail the mouth of
ickis from ariel monsters the mad
hatter's hat jimmy neutron's hair a
smurf hat rocky the squirrel's cap the
pink panther's mouth mr potato head's
body the key blade from kingdom hearts a
gloved mickey hand and bar talked the
bat's ears probably even more horrifying
stuff outside there is a 3d reporter
actually later we see the channel's 3d
chiron with some amazing jokes in the
ticker little drummer boy indicted on 14
counts of money laundering barney the
dinosaur starting a new religion on
wisconsin farm at the lapd there's
scruff mcgruff in the corner and
actually later you can see detective
flores from john melanie's other
animated show big mouth on netflix
outside the sidewalk there's a bench ad
reading vote senator butthead to get
tough on bootleg laws obviously from
beavers butthead now back at the
convention paul rudd cameos claiming
originally ant-man was aunt man there's
a ton more cosplayers here they get
caught in a stampede of my little ponies
jimmy pushes past a pickle rick and then
grabs the lost boy cubby from peter pan
chip and dale hide under he-man and
skeletor's table ship grabs the disguise
but just grabs indiana jones gear as
chip's look was based on indy while
dale's shirt was based on magnum pi more
cosplayers including borat and miguel
from pixar's coco they climb up a
voltron bob hits his head and sees seth
rogen's other animated characters pumbaa
from the 2019 lion king bob from
monsters vs aliens and mantis from kung
fu panda what are you looking at
honestly your weird dead eyes they are
weird
super weird
it's so funny and later when he gets
arrested bob claims jack skeleton has
been embezzling from his own charity for
years pete's torture tools include a jar
of dip that was the acid wash from who
framed roger rabbit love that making a
cameo here ellie is able to tip off dale
with the plot of the episode of rescue
rangers when you fish upon a star he's
able to reunite with gadget and zipper
chris parnell the voice of jerry from
rick and morty cameos as dale's agent
dave bolinari daley uses a firework with
mickey's fantasia hat to blast in the
lab and later it explodes into a
mickey's head shape with the when you
wish upon a star music the machine
explodes and zaps jimmy into one of the
sleepy beauty fairies and then zaps pete
into a horrifying monstrous form one
legged transformer one leg the leg of
woody from toy story one of his arms
wreck-it ralph arm he's wearing mickey
mouse's short pants looks like he's got
shredder's shoulder armor his other arm
looks like it's based on the cannon arm
mario and he has the face of marie from
aristocats they flee through the bootleg
movie sets including pooj the fat honey
bear a bootleg simpsons that actually
kind of looks like matt granian's
original designs from the 80s a bootleg
aladdin starring pete from goof troop
jim cummings voicing him here along with
darkwing duck in the mid-credit cameo
they glide magic carpet away and pete
roars after them the banner dropping in
front of him just like it did for the
t-rex in jurassic park meanwhile ellie
battles huddy who seeps under the door
with the same
sound effect as he 1000 and t2 judgement
day
and ellie freezes and shatters them
similar to how they initially stopped
the t-1000 but this is the final blow to
putty unlike it was for the t-1000 on
the docks there's a sign for nine men or
nina men boat shop which is a deep cut
nod to the disney nine old men who
famously helped shape walt disney's
iconic animation style they plot to drop
the bundle on pete as they did a fat cat
in episode 325 that was the episode they
were shooting in the opening of this
movie and then ugly sonic shows up with
the fbi but pete breaks free for one
last shot just like the die-hard action
movie trope but the commemorative pog
that chip gave dale saves his life so
they free the poor bootleg victims
including mixed matches of lots of
different characters i saw a boo donkey
kong jr bigfoot from the goofy movie
with the underwear on his head but he's
dressed like fred flintstone we see
patrick starr zazu from the lion king
woody woodpecker gus gus bonkers the
cheshire cat mighty mouse samurai jack
jiminy cricket bambi and a poor sad
sneezy cradling flounder we also see
toby the turtle from robin hood and what
happened to monty they dumbo'd him as
teased in the final lines of the movie
do you think we could get like a pop
star to do the theme song yeah right
like a super serious version even though
everyone just wants to hear the original
the credits feature a cover of the
chippendale theme song in this case by
post malone and one of my favorite
credits here was steven sackler the
production designer who you might have
seen if you look closely early in the
movie he snuck his name as the director
of the fast and furious babies movie
again rated r that plus meryl streep is
miss doubtfire we gotta see these at
some point but i want to know your
favorite cameo and reference in this
movie i'm sure i missed a lot so comment
down below if you spotted any others you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos following rockstar subscribe to
our sources for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you